let's do a little bit of review of
potential energy and especially
gravitational potential energy because
in this video we're going to get a
little bit more precise
so let's say that i have an object here
it has a mass of m
and i were to change its position in the
vertical direction we're assuming that
we are on earth where the gravitational
field is g and we have a change in the
vertical direction of delta y
so
this is its new position the mass of the
object of mass m
so what is its change in gravitational
potential energy
well we have seen this before our change
in potential energy due to gravity is
going to be the mass of our object times
the gravitational field times our change
in position in the vertical direction
now this is all good but there's a
couple of things that we can get a
little bit more precise or that we can
think about in this video one is we
assumed a constant gravitational field
and that's fine if we're near the
surface of a planet
and we also are just doing everything on
a relative basis but is there a way to
come up with an absolute number on what
is the gravitational potential energy
well to think about that let's just go
back to newton's law of gravity newton's
law of gravity tells us that if i have
two objects so this object has mass m1
this object has mass m2 and the distance
between their center of masses is r
that the magnitude of the force of
gravity and if the force of gravity is
acting in this direction on that object
it would have an equal and opposite
direction on that object right over
there
so the magnitude of the force of gravity
is going to be equal to the
gravitational constant times the product
of the two objects masses divided by the
radius squared
or another way to think about it if we
wanted to know the gravitational field
created by m2 well then you would just
divide both sides by m1 so if you divide
both sides by m1
you get that the gravitational field
actually isn't constant it is equal to
the gravitational constant
times
these cancel out
m2
the mass of the object generating the
gravitational field divided by r squared
and so this can actually help us come up
with an absolute formula for
gravitational potential energy we can
say that gravitational potential energy
and this is typically denoted with a
capital g over here is equal to
let's say the mass of the object and
let's just call that m1
the mass of the object times the
gravitational field so that's g
times the mass of the object creating
the field divided by r squared times the
height that this is above the center of
mass of the object generating the
gravitational field well what's that
well if this if this was earth you would
view r as well how far am i above the
center of mass of earth and so you would
multiply that times r
times r and so this r and an and one of
the r's and the r squared will cancel
out so that will just go away and then
this will just become an r
and now one thing to think about is what
should the potential energy be as r goes
to infinity well what is the
gravitational field as we go to infinity
as r gets really really really large
well as r gets really really really
large the gravitational field goes to
zero
but at the same time the further you get
away the higher the potential energy you
should have
and so the way that we've thought about
this is we say hey look let's just put a
negative out front you could just put it
right over here and then it all works
out that gravitational potential
energies are always going to be negative
but they get less negative the further
out you get to and at infinity it gets
to zero so let me rewrite this
the potential energy due to gravity can
be written as the negative of the
gravitational constant times the mass of
the first object times the mass of the
second object divided by r
and you can see this looks an awful lot
like newton's law of gravity what the
difference is we have a negative in
front of the gravitational constant
instead of dividing by r squared we only
divide by r
but this is really really really really
valuable now because now we have an
absolute sense of what gravitational
potential energy is and it meets all the
properties we need it would still meet
this idea that the further you get away
you will have an increase in
gravitational potential energy because
it's going to become less negative but
at the same time as you go to infinity
as r gets infinitely far your potential
energy is going to approach zero
so i will leave you there in future
videos we will apply this